Tasha:你把它拉这么长试试
Tasha: Try pulling it this long.
Tasha:对
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha:行然后我们再多拉几次
Tasha: Alright, let's pull it a few more times.
Tasha:拉这么长就行
Tasha: Pull it this long, that's enough.
Tasha:OK
Tasha: OK.
Tasha:差不多可以了
Tasha: Almost done.
Tasha:我第一次把它放这么久拉
Tasha: It's my first time letting it sit this long.
Jake:会有差别吗
Jake: Will it make a difference?
Tasha:不知道耶
Tasha: I don't know.
Jake:哎哟 我去
Jake: Oh man.
Tasha:好了好了
Tasha: Alright, alright.
Tasha:算了来吧
Tasha: Forget it, let's go.
Jake:为什么还要再打几次
Jake: Why do we have to do it a few more times?
Jake:这个麻糬对吧
Jake: This is mochi, right?
Tasha:对你拉
Tasha: Yeah, you pull it.
Tasha:然后你把它们放在这个球这个碗里
Tasha: Then you put them into this bowl.
Tasha:必须要由你来放干净因为
Tasha: You have to do it cleanly because
Tasha:嗯第二个摸面团的人
Tasha: the second person who touches the dough
Tasha:手就会被粘住
Tasha: will have their hands stuck.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha:手
Tasha: Hands.
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why?
Tasha:面团很 柔  你你手上有油了
Tasha: The dough is very soft and your hands are already oily.
Tasha:那个黄油在你手上
Tasha: That butter is on your hands.
Tasha:你想让你再揉一会吧我帮你搞个配件
Tasha: Do you want to knead it a bit more? I'll get you a tool.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:这个是水
Tasha: This is water.
Tasha:好求你
Tasha: Please.
Tasha:好然后下一锅子
Tasha: Alright, then the next batch.
Tasha:我等一下就告诉你
Tasha: I'll tell you in a bit.
Tasha:你也好了
Tasha: You're done too.
Tasha:嗯 你把它挤出一个球来你懂吗
Tasha: Hmm, you squeeze it into a ball, you know?
Jake:我试试
Jake: Let me try.
Tasha:对就这样子
Tasha: Yes, just like that.
Shure: 那个杨老板
Shure: Hey Jake.
Tasha:哎干嘛
Tasha: Hey, what's up?
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:手机号啊
Jake: The phone number?
Jake:哎哎哎帮我把手机拿出来
Jake: Hey, hey, hey, help me get my phone out.
Jake:我靠你看
Jake: Whoa, look at this.
Tasha:哇你真厉害哎
Tasha: Wow, you're amazing.
Jake:好玩
Jake: It's fun.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:爱玩
Jake: I love it.
Tasha:你已经爱上厨房了
Tasha: You've fallen in love with the kitchen.
Jake:对确实
Jake: Yeah, definitely.
Tasha:手机在哪里哦
Tasha: Where's my phone?
Jake:在我在我兜里
Jake: It's in my pocket.
Tasha:哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake:打开刷我的脸
Jake: Unlock it with my face.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh.
Tasha:然后
Tasha: Then?
Jake:打打电话
Jake: Make a call.
Jake:哎那谢彬竹去哪了
Jake: Hey, where did Xie Binzhu go?
Tasha:谢谢明竹去哪了
Tasha: Where did Xie Mingzhu go?
Jake:谢谢彬竹
Jake: Xie Binzhu.
Jake:就刚刚那小伙
Jake: That guy just now.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha:他跟他出去了吗
Tasha: Did he go out with him?
Jake:路亚他玩狗的时候
Jake: When Luyah was playing with the dog.
Jake:这个不是被狗抓了一下吗
Jake: Didn't the dog scratch him?
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:然后他觉得不放心
Jake: Then he felt uneasy.
Jake:他去打疫苗去了
Jake: So he went to get vaccinated.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:然后他我们我们也不放心
Jake: And we were worried too.
Jake:所以派小伙去接他了
Jake: So we sent the guy to pick him up.
Jake:然后那小伙接就
Jake: But the guy couldn't reach Luyah.
Jake:就是联系不上露亚
Jake: So they're figuring it out.
Jake:然后再想办法
Jake: Let's think of something else.
小薇 我刷到什么
Tasha: What did I swipe to?
Jake:关了吧 打电话给谢彬竹退出去
Jake: Turn it off. Call Xie Binzhu and exit.
Tasha:这个是吗
Tasha: Is this it?
Jake:对打
Jake: Yes, call.
Tasha:这个不是视频
Tasha: This isn't a video.
Nicous: 喂
Nicous: Hello?
Jake:你在哪
Jake: Where are you?
Nicous: 我在门口
Nicous: I'm at the door.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:啊卧槽
Jake: Ah, damn it.
Jake:那你他妈进来不就行了吗
Jake: Why didn't you just come in?
Jake:打什么电话呀
Jake: Why are you making a call?
Nicous: 不是 刚刚
Nicous: No, just now...
Tasha:拿把伞
Tasha: Get an umbrella.
Jake:拿把伞干嘛
Jake: What do you need an umbrella for?
Shure: 他他要把伞
Shure: He, he needs an umbrella.
Nicous: 刚刚在
Nicous: Just now at...
Jake:下雨了
Jake: It was raining.
Nicous: 刚刚在咖啡厅
Nicous: Just now at the café...
Nicous: 就下雨了
Nicous: It started raining.
Nicous: 回来拿把伞
Nicous: Came back to get an umbrella.
Nicous: 她有手机号吗
Nicous: Does she have a phone number?
Nicous: 她 没理我
Nicous: She ignored me.
Jake:我靠这么牛逼
Jake: Wow, that's impressive.
Jake:这样
Jake: Like this.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake:来 拿着你给谢彬竹拿着
Jake: Here, take this to Xie Binzhu.
Jake:然后退回去
Jake: Then come back.
Jake:露亚
Jake: Lucia.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake:你点你点你点你点
Jake: You click, you click, you click.
Jake:然后点头像
Jake: Then click the profile picture.
Jake:对哎我操
Jake: Yes, oh damn.
Jake:他不应该有的
Jake: He shouldn't have it.
Nicous: 她不是有简历吗
Nicous: Doesn't she have a resume?
Jake:有简历
Jake: She has a resume.
Tasha:文件找文件找文件
Tasha: Find the file, find the file.
Jake:找文件
Jake: Find the file.
Jake:有吗
Jake: Got it?
Nicous: 有
Nicous: Got it.
Jake:有
Jake: Got it.
Jake:行
Jake: Okay.
Jake:行行行来
Jake: Okay, okay, okay, come on.
Jake:那个你你先打个电话吧
Jake: You, you make a call first.
Jake:先打个电话
Jake: Make a call first.
Jake:喂露亚我是谢宾珠我来接你了就是这样
Jake: Hello Lucia, this is Xie Binzhu, I'm here to pick you up, that's it.
Tasha:搓球吧
Tasha: Let's play ping pong.
Jake:好行
Jake: Alright.
Jake:我把
Jake: I'll...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:哦行
Jake: Oh, okay.
Tasha:让他搓个球怎么这么难
Tasha: Why is it so hard for him to roll a ball?
Tasha:你知道催他多少遍了吗
Tasha: Do you know how many times I've pushed him?
Tasha:他就一直拿在手上玩
Tasha: He just keeps playing with it in his hand.
Nicous: 我遇到到一个困扰
Nicous: I ran into a problem.
Tasha:唉接了接了
Tasha: Hey, he picked up.
Jake: :她眼镜是在下面吗
Jake: Are her glasses down there?
Tasha:哎呦
Tasha: Oh my!
Nicous: 喂喂喂
Nicous: Hey, hey, hey.
Nicous: 跟说说我是谢彬竹
Nicous: Tell them I'm Xie Binzhu.
Jake:你去拿充电宝
Jake: Go get a power bank.
Alice:拿几个啊
Alice: How many should I get?
Jake:在这边
Jake: Over here.
Jake:拿一个
Jake: Just get one.
Jake:拿一个就够你拿个高的
Jake: One is enough, get a tall one.
Jake:40吧 他没这么高呢那个不是更高吗
Jake: About 40. He’s not that tall, isn't that one taller?
Jake:那个后面的
Jake: The one in the back.
Jake:我靠不行那就拿40走
Jake: Oh no, just get the 40.
Alice:我去哪里接她
Alice: Where should I pick her up?
Jake:啊你跟谢彬竹走
Jake: Uh, go with Xie Binzhu.
Alice:那我换个鞋吧
Alice: I'll change my shoes then.
Jake:那个他的定位给发给我了
Jake: He sent me the location already.
Jake:顺着那个定位过去就行
Jake: Just follow the location.
Tasha:开车你好像可以不换鞋
Tasha: You can drive without changing shoes.
Alice:开车去的吗
Alice: Are we driving there?
Tasha:应该是
Tasha: Probably.
Tasha:是开车去吗
Tasha: Are we driving there?
Tasha:打车去
Tasha: Take a taxi.
Alice:这么远吗
Alice: Is it that far?
Jake:没有很远就是安全一点
Jake: Not very far, just to be safe.
Jake:来 我要干嘛
Jake: Okay, what should I do?
Tasha:您挤吧 挤
Tasha: Squeeze it, squeeze.
Tasha:就是这样挤一个出来
Tasha: Just squeeze it out like this.
Nicous: 也 她刚和我说的
Nicous: Yeah, she just told me.
Tasha:大了
Tasha: It's too big.
Tasha:啊对 然后捏出来
Tasha: Yeah, then pinch it out.
Tasha:捏啊用另一只手
Tasha: Pinch it with the other hand.
Tasha:先捏个团子 然后 嗯
Tasha: First make a ball, then... hmm.
Tasha:唵
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:行吧
Jake: Alright then.
Tasha:好大哦
Tasha: It's so big.
Jake:什么
Jake: What?
Tasha:好粘啊你别搞这么粘乎呀
Tasha: It's so sticky, don't make it so sticky.
Tasha:就直接挤进去就行
Tasha: Just squeeze it in directly.
Tasha:你放进去
Tasha: Put it in.
Jake:它为什么这么粘
Jake: Why is it so sticky?
Tasha:就是所以我的手更不能沾
Tasha: That's why my hands shouldn't touch it.
Tasha:你都已经这么粘了
Tasha: You've already made it so sticky.
Jake:哇靠
Jake: Oh gosh.
Jake:这这这地方我我一只手搞能搞定吗
Jake: Can I handle this with one hand?
Tasha:搞不定
Tasha: No, you can't.
Jake:谢谢 我能搞定
Jake: Thanks, I can handle it.
Tasha:别用别用那一只手啊 哈
Tasha: Don't use just one hand, haha.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake:这样这样是不是挺好
Jake: Is this okay like this?
Tasha:我 两只手可以搞定的
Tasha: I can handle it with both hands.
Shure: 怎么样 这个唱能吗
Shure: How about this? Can you sing this?
Jake:这样这样行吗
Jake: Is this okay?
Tasha:可以了 你扔进去就行了
Tasha: Yes, just throw it in.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Tasha:这 这也挤点
Tasha: Squeeze this too.
Tasha:大概挤3-5个就可以
Tasha: Squeeze about 3-5 of them.
Tasha:换
Tasha: Switch.
Tasha:可以换
Tasha: You can switch.
Tasha:全部挤出来就行了
Tasha: Just squeeze them all out.
Jake:这个太大了
Jake: This is too big.
Tasha:好好好没事没事你想多大多大
Tasha: It's okay, make it as big as you want.
Jake:哈哈哈这个我喜欢
Jake: Haha, I like this.
Jake:这么说话我就喜欢
Jake: I like it when you talk like this.
Tasha:揪出来就这样直接扔进去好吧
Tasha: Just pull it out and throw it in directly, okay?
Tasha:好吧哈哈哈
Tasha: Okay, haha.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake:为什么可以怎么可以
Jake: Why can it be like this?
Tasha:它太喜欢你啦
Tasha: It likes you too much.
Jake:暂时不用我靠
Jake: Not for now, gosh.
Jake:我靠哈哈哈
Jake: Gosh, haha.
Jake:吃的时候你才喜欢我
Jake: You only like me when it's time to eat.
Tasha:每一个麻薯上面都沾满着杨老师的手
Tasha: Every mochi has Jake's handprints on it.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Gosh.
Tasha:手
Tasha: Hands
Jake:下不去啊
Jake: I can't get it down
Tasha:手套要是破了话这个时候就很好弄了
Tasha: If the glove is broken, it's easier to handle
Jake:那这不破了吗
Jake: Isn't it broken now?
Tasha:为什么破
Tasha: Why is it broken?
Tasha:你不
Tasha: You didn't
Jake:是不是太大了
Jake: Is it too big?
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay
Tasha:没事继续挤吧
Tasha: It's okay, keep squeezing
Tasha:给他翻个面你也可以继续挤
Tasha: Flip it over and you can keep squeezing
Tasha:太粘了抓紧点
Tasha: It's too sticky, hold it tighter
Tasha:你也给拉紧
Tasha: You also need to pull it tight
Jake:我为什么只有5只手指
Jake: Why do I only have 5 fingers?
Tasha:你还想要几只
Tasha: How many do you want?
Tasha:我来满足你的愿望
Tasha: I'll make your wish come true
Jake:你怎么满足我的愿望
Jake: How will you make my wish come true?
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:来哈哈哈
Jake: Come on, hahaha
Jake:不好 就这样子
Jake: Not good, just like this
Tasha:哎 您尽量往粉上倒呀
Tasha: Hey, try to pour it on the powder
Tasha:您往壁个倒不太好扒拉下来
Tasha: Pouring it on the side is hard to scrape off
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Tasha:您看
Tasha: Look
Jake:好 可以
Jake: Okay, got it
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah
Jake:好我错了
Jake: Okay, my bad
Tasha:好好好我来吧你的手
Tasha: Okay, okay, let me do it, your hands
Tasha:这样子的话面团上面就都是巧克力
Tasha: This way the dough will be covered in chocolate
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Tasha:所以这个步骤需要两个人
Tasha: So this step needs two people
Jake:我明白
Jake: I understand
Tasha:其实你那个步骤很好玩的
Tasha: Actually, your step is fun
Tasha:只不过你的手套不好
Tasha: But your glove is not good
Jake:为什么只有一个手套呢一双手套呢
Jake: Why do I only have one glove? Shouldn't I have a pair?
Tasha:因为一共买了5双
Tasha: Because we only bought 5 pairs
Tasha:没想到这么快就用完了
Tasha: Didn't expect them to run out so quickly
Tasha:我一开始就应该买50双
Tasha: I should have bought 50 pairs from the start
Tasha:你看其实别的有手套是不粘的对吧
Tasha: See, with gloves, it's not sticky, right?
Jake:挺好 有手套的那一边
Jake: Yeah, the side with the glove is good
Tasha:想吃哪一个
Tasha: Which one do you want to eat?
Tasha:偷偷吃一点
Tasha: Sneak a bite.
Jake:这个小配菜挺好看的
Jake: This little side dish looks pretty nice.
Tasha:是吧
Tasha: Right?
Jake:我去太粘了
Jake: Oh no, it's too sticky.
Tasha:先夹住这个然后然后粘这个
Tasha: First, grab this, then dip it in this.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha:粘这个然后粘这个就可以吃到了
Tasha: Dip it in this, then dip it in that, and you can eat it.
Jake:还挺好
Jake: It's pretty good.
Jake:这是什么是什么东西怎么是这样的
Jake: What is this? What kind of thing is this?
Tasha:炼奶 对
Tasha: Condensed milk, yes.
Jake:炼奶
Jake: Condensed milk?
Tasha:奶盖
Tasha: Milk foam.
Tasha:意思就是
Tasha: It means...
Tasha:哦哟我哟哦哟我哟
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Tasha:OK
Tasha: OK.
Tasha:您是不是又忘记了我教您的
Tasha: Did you forget what I taught you again?
Tasha:让它着陆于有粉的地方
Tasha: Let it land on the powdered area.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake:有粉的方不多了
Jake: There's not much powdered area left.
Tasha:这个盆好像有点大
Tasha: This bowl seems a bit big.
Tasha:这好小呀
Tasha: This is so small.
Tasha:哈哈你是为了弥补谁吗
Tasha: Haha, are you trying to make up for someone?
Jake:4号
Jake: Number 4.
Jake:我想起了4号
Jake: I remember number 4.
Tasha:看得出来你弄得很不愉快
Tasha: I can tell you're not enjoying it.
Jake:很难愉快
Jake: It's hard to enjoy.
Jake:这个哎呦我靠好
Jake: This, oh wow, it's good.
Jake:哈哈哈太nice you wait
Jake: Hahaha, so nice you wait.
Tasha:所以我一开始建议你要不把手套取了
Tasha: That's why I initially suggested you take off the gloves.
Tasha:直接揉这样的话
Tasha: Just knead it directly, that way...
Jake:好建议但是没有采纳
Jake: Good suggestion, but I didn't take it.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:并不知道
Jake: Didn't know.
Jake:它原来道理在这里
Jake: So that's the trick.
Tasha:好好好好
Tasha: Alright, alright, alright.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh no.
Tasha:你把全部的搓完就行了这就结束了
Tasha: Just finish rolling all of them, then you're done.
Jake:好好难啊
Jake: It's so difficult.
Tasha:不好玩了吗
Tasha: Not fun anymore?
Jake:好好好好玩
Jake: Still fun, still fun.
Jake:哈哈哈那就难度有点高我草
Jake:我好像坐着搓
Jake:我站着站不住
Tasha:我一开始其实觉得挺好搓的
Tasha:你知道吗
Tasha:直到你把手套弄破
Jake:那真的就一个吗
Tasha:在此时换下是更不明智的选择
Tasha:OK OK  这个这个 雨露均沾一下吧
Tasha:子落提
Tasha:电
Jake:耶
Tasha:q弹还拉丝
Jake:不行不行
Jake:破了
Tasha:这是麻薯你看你掌握了
Jake:哎我去
Tasha:全部的拉丝过程
Jake:我靠
Tasha:哈哈哈受不了了
Tasha: Hahaha, I can't take it anymore.
Jake:哎呀 我操 这个粘粉了
Jake: Oh man, damn, this got sticky.
Tasha:没事没事没事
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Jake:挤
Jake: Squeeze it.
Tasha:收 行行行
Tasha: Got it, got it.
Tasha:没有人看到它的制作过程
Tasha: No one saw how it was made.
Tasha:就不会觉得它恶心
Tasha: They wouldn't think it's gross.
Jake:其实随便一什么形状我都能揉成圆的对吗
Jake: Actually, I can shape it into a ball from any form, right?
Tasha:是的
Tasha: Yep.
Jake:那我就会
Jake: Then I can do it.
Jake:你想上去唱歌吗
Jake: Do you want to go up and sing?
Tasha:我不想唱没他那么好听
Tasha: I don't want to sing, I'm not as good as him.
Tasha:那我就是个垃圾了
Tasha: Then I'm just trash.
Jake:那不不不不
Jake: No, no, no, no.
Jake:欧耶
Jake: Oh yeah.
Jake:这是我的手机
Jake: This is my phone.
Tasha:YES
Tasha: YES.
Tasha:哇 刚刚把它完成
Tasha: Wow, just finished it.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Jake:这个可以
Jake: This one works.
Jake:这个我很满意
Jake: I’m really satisfied with this.
Tasha:杨老板改做巧克力味的了
Tasha: Jake switched to making chocolate-flavored ones.
Tasha:你是不是觉得这边没关系
Tasha: Do you think it doesn't matter over here?
Jake:这个这个
Jake: This, this…
Jake:要不铺平点
Jake: Maybe flatten it out a bit?
Jake:也行吧
Jake: That works too.
Jake:因为我没有落地的地方
Jake: Because I have no place to land.
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Tasha:是的
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha:你看其实给你配一个助手
Tasha: Look, if you had an assistant...
Tasha:你就能做出很好的甜品了
Tasha: You could make really good desserts.
Jake:哇这么好
Jake: Wow, that’s great.
Tasha:要不要考虑考虑招募我哈哈哈
Tasha: Have you considered recruiting me, haha?
Tasha:这这这你挤给谁吃的
Tasha: Who did you squeeze this for?
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:太傻了
Jake: So silly.
Tasha:要尝尝巧克力味的吗
Tasha: Want to try the chocolate flavor?
Jake:好
Jake: Sure.
Jake:你吃了吗
Jake: Have you tried it?
Tasha:我我知道味道
Tasha: I know the taste.
Tasha:吃了好多次
Tasha: I've had it many times.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Tasha:总体来说还挺好吃的
Tasha: Overall, it's pretty good.
Jake:确实也小
Jake: Indeed, it's a bit small.
Tasha:你给自己挤个大的吧
Tasha: Make a bigger one for yourself.
Tasha:哎呦我天呢
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Tasha:有点像黑心作坊的感觉
Tasha: It's kind of like a shady workshop.
Jake:为啥
Jake: Why?
Tasha:就是两个人
Tasha: Just the two of us.
Jake:嚯一般的店家不是这么做吗
Jake: Isn't this how most shops do it?
Tasha:嗯会无菌上的吧
Tasha: Hmm, they would usually be sterile.
Jake:好好好无菌怎么做
Jake: Okay, okay, how do you make it sterile?
Tasha:戴上正规手套
Tasha: Wear proper gloves.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Tasha:哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha:而不是一个徒手一个戴破手套
Tasha: Not one person with bare hands and the other with torn gloves.
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:耶这个可以
Jake: Yay, this works.
Jake:我们到时候那个盘子
Jake: Our plate at that time...
Jake:里面放多少种类
Jake: How many types do we put inside?
Tasha:放什么多少种
Tasha: What types are we putting?
Jake:甜品
Jake: Desserts.
Jake:外边的盘子大
Jake: The outer plate is big.
Tasha:呃
Tasha: Uh...
Tasha:每个盘子放一种的话那得做很久吧
Tasha: If we put one type on each plate, it will take a long time, right?
Tasha:不过没关系
Tasha: But it's fine.
Jake:可以做很久
Jake: It can take a long time.
Tasha:可以做很久
Tasha: It can take a long time.
Jake:从昨天从明天开始做
Jake: Start making it from yesterday, from tomorrow.
Jake:从明天开始做
Jake: Start making it from tomorrow.
Tasha:那你明天开始别休息了
Tasha: Then you won't get any rest from tomorrow.
Jake:真的这么多
Jake: Really that many?
Jake:是吗
Jake: Is it?
Tasha:什么这么多啊
Tasha: What's that many?
Jake:哎呦好吃
Jake: Oh, this is delicious.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Tasha:再来个巧克力味的啊哈
Tasha: Let's have another chocolate one, haha.
Jake:哎呀 我靠
Jake: Oh my, damn.
Tasha:不敢想这个怎么这个样子
Tasha: I can't believe how this turned out like this.
Jake:真好真好
Jake: Really good, really good.
Tasha:耶这麻薯搓的很有杨老板的风格
Tasha: Yeah, this mochi has Jake's style.
Tasha:就是每一个都独自形状
Tasha: Each one has its own unique shape.
Jake:不是我的
Jake: It's not mine.
Jake:昨天那个奶油好歹我还是想给他一点
Jake: Yesterday's cream, I still wanted to give it some shape.
Jake:形状
Jake: Shape.
Jake:就是昨天那个煮完了
Jake: Yesterday's was cooked.
Jake:今天这个我
Jake: Today this one, I...
Tasha:被动的
Tasha: Passive.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:好剩下好多粉就倒上去吗
Jake: Okay, just pour the rest of the powder?
Tasha:不要了
Tasha: No more.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Okay.
Jake:耶 我觉得我要完工了
Jake: Yeah, I think I'm done.
Jake:来呗
Jake: Come on.
Tasha:把这个最丑的给你吃掉
Tasha: Eat the ugliest one yourself.
Tasha:稍为好看一点的留给别人
Tasha: Save the better-looking ones for others.
Jake:留着
Jake: Keep them.
Jake:我这个怎么办
Jake: What about this one?
Tasha:可以洗手了
Tasha: You can wash your hands now.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my god
Jake:这玩意怎么洗啊
Jake: How do you wash this thing?
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn it
Tasha:有点难洗吗
Tasha: Is it hard to wash?
Jake:有有点难洗
Jake: Yeah, it's a bit hard to wash.
Tasha:其实我的手也不好看
Tasha: Actually, my hands don't look good either.
Jake:那你先洗
Jake: Then you wash first.
Tasha:哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake:我到那边我用洗手液试试
Jake: I'll try using hand soap over there.
Tasha:呃洗洁
Tasha: Uh, dish soap.
Tasha:呃
Tasha: Uh...
Jake:你的手好洗吗
Jake: Are your hands easy to clean?
Tasha:我洗完了
Tasha: I've finished washing them.
Jake:洗完了
Jake: Finished?
Jake:帮我看看我的手机我靠
Jake: Check my phone, damn it.
Jake:我这手机是不是要洗
Jake: Does my phone need to be washed?
Tasha:完了完了完了完
Tasha: It's done, it's done, it's done.
Jake:完球
Jake: It's over.
Jake:我完了
Jake: I'm done for.
Tasha:稍微看下谁给你发短信了吗
Tasha: Take a quick look at who sent you a message.
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Tasha:呃
Tasha: Uh...
Tasha:要干嘛吗
Tasha: Do you need anything?
Jake:啊要要要
Jake: Uh, yes, yes.
Jake:打个电话给谢彬竹
Jake: Call Xie Binzhu.
Shure: 嗯差不多
Shure: Yeah, almost done.
Tasha:洗好了吗
Tasha: Are you done washing?
Tasha:洗完 洗
Tasha: Finished?
Jake:没没没 没洗
Jake: No, no, no, not yet.
Tasha:能洗吗
Tasha: Can you wash it?
Jake:不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake:我觉得有用
Jake: I think it's useful.
Tasha:怎么一个两个都不接电话呢
Tasha: Why is no one answering the phone?
Jake:一个两个都叫不起来
Jake: No one is waking up.
Jake:起床
Jake: Wake up.
Tasha:说谁呢
Tasha: Who are you talking about?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:好了ok
Jake: Alright, okay.
Jake:哎不接算了
Jake: Hey, forget it, don't answer.
Jake:不接一会再打一次
Jake: Don't answer, we'll call again later.
Tasha:还有两个
Tasha: There's still two more.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:是被遗落的
Tasha: They were left behind.
Jake:为什么被遗落呢
Jake: Why were they left behind?
Tasha:嗯好吧
Tasha: Hmm, okay.
Tasha:唉
Tasha: Sigh.
Jake:唉等会
Jake: Wait a minute.
Tasha:喂
Tasha: Hello?
Nicous: 喂 喂 喂
Nicous: Hello, hello, hello.
Tasha:问你接到了吗应该是呃
Tasha: Did you get it? Should be...
Nicous: 啊 还有十分钟能回来
Nicous: Ah, I'll be back in ten minutes.
Nicous: 马上过去了 刚才那个
Nicous: I'm almost there. Just now...
Nicous: 导航导了半个小时快
Nicous: The navigation took almost half an hour.
Nicous: 耽误了点时间
Nicous: It delayed me a bit.
Tasha:哦行
Tasha: Oh, okay.
Jake:还用又又用这个
Jake: You still had to use this again?
Nicous: 还真是
Nicous: Yeah, really.
Jake:哎呦我操
Jake: Oh my god.
Nicous: 啊
Nicous: Yeah?
Jake:你现在什么情况啊
Jake: What's your situation now?
Nicous: 现在马上还有
Nicous: I'm almost there, and...
Nicous: 还有
Nicous: And...
Nicous: 还有三四分钟就见到她了
Nicous: I'll see her in three or four minutes.
Jake:好 行行
Jake: Alright, okay.
Jake:行  好
Jake: Okay, good.
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright.
Tasha:好完全不耽误事
Tasha: Okay, it won't delay anything.
Tasha:我们比他们还快嘞.
Tasha: We're even faster than them.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha:都完成了
Tasha: It's all done.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Tasha:那你等我呢
Tasha: So, you're waiting for me?
Tasha:哎呦
Tasha: Oh my.
Tasha:are you lady
Tasha: Are you lady?
Jake:ready怎么吃
Jake: Ready, how do you eat it?
Jake:你你不 吃啊
Jake: Aren't you eating?
Tasha:我吃过一个了好吃吗
Tasha: I already had one, was it good?
Jake:好吃
Jake: Delicious.
Tasha:行
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha:你怎么蘸这么点
Tasha: Why did you dip so little?
Tasha:你应该多蘸一点
Tasha: You should dip more.
Jake:我感觉我要插电
Jake: I think I need to plug in.
Jake:我看一眼我要不要插电了
Jake: Let me check if I need to plug in.
Jake:我要插电了
Jake: I need to plug in.
Tasha:然后把这两个端上去就行
Tasha: And then just bring these two up.
Tasha:完成了
Tasha: Done.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Tasha:不要浪费了
Tasha: Don't waste it.
Jake:我们插个电吧
Jake: Let's plug it in.
Tasha:你去吧
Tasha: You go ahead.
Tasha:哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake:哦有电了我操
Jake: Oh, it's got power now.
Tasha:对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:帮忙
Jake: Help.
Tasha:噢 天呢
Tasha: Oh my god.
Jake:谢谢你
Jake: Thank you.
Jake:现在是一个
Jake: Now it's a...
Jake:不大用手的人
Jake: Not a hands-on person.
Jake:好粘还是好粘
Jake: Still sticky, still sticky.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake:这干嘛呀
Jake: What's this for?
Tasha:草莓熟透了你看
Tasha: The strawberries are ripe, look.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:看到了要把它干掉
Jake: Got it, need to finish it.
Tasha:是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:芒果这边要把它干掉
Jake: The mango here, need to finish it.
Jake:Mango我要吃Mango
Jake: Mango, I want to eat mango.
Tasha:Mango is in bread
Tasha: Mango is in bread.
Jake:吃bread
Jake: Eat bread.
Jake:哦 你还活着
Jake: Oh, you're still alive.
Jake:放着吧 今晚收拾吧
Jake: Leave it, we'll clean it up tonight.
Jake:这玩意怎么收呢
Jake: How do we clean this up?
Tasha:怎么收
Tasha: How to clean?
Jake:怎么把它给解决掉
Jake: How do we get rid of it?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha:直接吃掉
Tasha: Just eat it.
Jake:好给你
Jake: Alright, here you go.
Jake:给你一个
Jake: Here, one for you.
Jake:你不吃了吗
Jake: Aren't you eating?
Tasha:一人一个呀
Tasha: One for each of us.
Jake:也行
Jake: Okay, that's fine.
Tasha:好了我们偷偷把草莓给干掉
Tasha: Alright, let's secretly finish the strawberries.
Jake:下一步就是
Jake: The next step is...
Jake:是不是多少过分了点
Jake: Isn't this a bit too much?
Jake:要不等他们回来
Jake: How about we wait for them to come back?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:嗯等他们分点
Jake: Yeah, wait for them and share a bit.
Jake:我先给弄上去
Jake: I'll put it up first.
Jake:好不
Jake: Is that okay?
Tasha:行可以啊
Tasha: Sure, that's fine.
Tasha:走吧
Tasha: Let's go.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha:你有东西要拿吗
Tasha: Do you need to bring anything?
Katrina: 嗯你要是一一点的歌的话
Katrina: Hmm, if you want a song at one o'clock...
Tasha:你手机呢
Tasha: Where's your phone?
Tasha:你看
Tasha: Look.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Shure: 我现在在思考
Shure: I'm thinking right now.
Shure: 定下歌曲
Shure: Finalizing the song.
Jake:自己作词
Jake: Writing the lyrics yourself?
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Katrina: 你就唱草履虫拉倒吧
Katrina: Just sing the amoeba song already.
Alice:打针疼吗挺疼的吧
Alice: Does getting a shot hurt? It must hurt a lot, right?
Jake:你把词写了让人唱
Jake: You write the lyrics and have someone else sing it.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Jake:这是我刚刚
Jake: I just...
Katrina: 然后看看看看刚
Katrina: Look, look, look...
Jake:学习的
Jake: Learning.
Tasha:老师做的
Tasha: The teacher did it.
Lucia:我本来想着也没啥事
Lucia: I was thinking there wasn't much to do anyway.
Tasha:杨老师做的
Tasha: Teacher Jake did it.
Jake:学习的
Jake: Learning.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Tasha:你有没有发现你没有带筷子上来
Tasha: Did you realize you didn't bring chopsticks up?
Jake:确实
Jake: True.
Tasha:大家怎么吃啊
Tasha: How is everyone going to eat?
Katrina: 这已经做好了
Katrina: It's already done.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina: 好厉害啊
Katrina: So impressive.
Katrina: 这东西做的很快吗居然
Katrina: This was made so quickly!
Jake:这东西做的我馋死了
Jake: This thing makes me so hungry.
Jake:我靠满手的这个
Jake: My hands are covered in this stuff.
Shure: 面
Shure: Dough
Jake:黏的
Jake: Sticky
Katrina: 我要拍一张照片
Katrina: I want to take a picture.
Jake:可粘了洗了10分钟的手
Jake: So sticky, washed my hands for 10 minutes.
Katrina: 哎 露西和爱丽丝呢
Katrina: Hey, where are Lucia and Alice?
Jake:他要是 哎露西呢
Jake: If he... hey, where's Lucia?
Tasha:我们就坐在这是吗
Tasha: Are we just sitting here?
Jake:我们就坐在这
Jake: We're just sitting here.
Tasha:你要不要把大垫子拖出来
Tasha: Do you want to bring out the big mat?
Jake:大垫子
Jake: Big mat?
Shure: 就把那个
Shure: Just that one
Jake:哦你的那个大垫子也用不着吧
Jake: Oh, you probably don't need your big mat.
Tasha:行
Tasha: Alright.
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need.
Jake:就这个足够了
Jake: This is enough.
Katrina: 那就一起讨论呗
Katrina: Let's discuss it together then.
Jake:来桃子桃子
Jake: Come on, peaches, peaches.
Shure: 露西亚你会唱是吧
Shure: Lucia, you can sing, right?
Katrina: 他不是露西亚
Katrina: He's not Lucia.
Katrina: 他是微微
Katrina: He's Weiwei.
Jake:你完了
Jake: You're done for.
Shure: 你叫什么露西亚
Shure: Why do you call him Lucia?
Katrina: 我是子轩
Katrina: I'm Zixuan.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我是子轩
Katrina: Hahaha, I'm Zixuan.
Jake:子轩好 你好子轩
Jake: Hello, Zixuan. Nice to meet you, Zixuan.
Tasha:你完了
Tasha: You're done for.
Jake:你好子轩
Jake: Nice to meet you, Zixuan.
Jake:不 不 不
Jake: No, no, no.
Katrina: 他是露西亚我是
Katrina: He's Lucia, I'm
Tasha:我叫什么
Tasha: What's my name?
Jake:我是露西亚
Jake: I'm Lucia.
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Shure: 你你叫塔莎
Shure: No, you're Tasha.
Jake:我叫什么
Jake: What's my name?
Jake:我叫露西亚
Jake: My name is Lucia.
Shure: 你叫Jing Kang
Shure: Your name is Jing Kang.
Jake:我靠什么东西
Jake: What the heck?
Tasha:他就只能叫他有他
Tasha: He can only be called that.
Tasha:他有英文名吗
Tasha: Does he have an English name?
Shure: Jing Kang
Shure: Jing Kang.
Tasha:你有英文名吗
Tasha: Do you have an English name?
Jake:我可以有
Jake: I can have one.
Jake:给给一个
Jake: Give me one.
Shure: JK young
Shure: JK Young.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:我靠
Jake: What the heck.
Shure: number seven JKyoung
Shure: Number seven, JK Young.
Jake:为什么seven
Jake: Why seven?
Jake:为什么是seven啊
Jake: Why is it seven?
Shure: 没有就是脑袋里面第一个蹦的
Shure: No reason, it's just the first thing that popped into my head.
Shure: 就是number seven
Shure: Just number seven.
Shure: 韦世豪哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Wei Shihao, hahaha.
Shure: 什么你不知道这个梗吗
Shure: What, you don't know this meme?
Jake:再说一遍
Jake: Say it again.
Shure: number seven韦世豪
Shure: Number seven, Wei Shihao.
Jake:韦世豪我知道了啊
Jake: I know Wei Shihao.
Shure: 然后哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: And then, hahaha.
Jake:我上回看到踢球了
Jake: I saw him playing soccer last time.
Jake:在那个中国队踢平新加坡
Jake: In that match where China tied with Singapore.
Jake:逼平新加坡啊
Jake: Forced a tie with Singapore, huh.
Jake:对中国国足
Jake: For the Chinese national soccer team.
Jake:逼平新家坡
Jake: Forced a tie with Singapore.
Shure: 想想塔莎
Shure: Think about Tasha.
Tasha:干嘛
Tasha: What's up?
Katrina: 想一首大家都会的欢快的歌
Katrina: Think of a fun song everyone knows.
Shure: 你们也可以唱你家乡的歌
Shure: You can also sing a song from your hometown.
Tasha:那必须要唱那种EMO神曲
Tasha: Then it has to be one of those emo classics.
Katrina: EMO选了一个
Katrina: Emo, pick one.
Katrina: 那个安静一点
Katrina: Something quiet.
Katrina: 要么唯一
Katrina: Maybe "The One."
Katrina: 要么就那个perfect
Katrina: Or "Perfect."
Katrina: 就黄老板那个
Katrina: That one by Ed Sheeran.
Katrina: 应该这个
Katrina: Should be that one.
Katrina: 这两个大家都比较熟吧
Katrina: These two are pretty well-known, right?
Shure: 那唱那什么吧
Shure: Then sing, um, what?
Shure: 唱卡丘莎
Shure: Sing "Katyusha."
Shure: 你家乡的小曲
Shure: A little tune from your hometown.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure: 想想动动你聪明的小脑瓜
Shure: Think and use that smart little brain of yours.
Katrina: 看看你刚刚那个new boy
Katrina: Look at that new boy you just mentioned.
Katrina: new boy
Katrina: New boy.
Katrina: 咱俩唱太难听了
Katrina: We both sing so terribly.
Shure: 把把我去了
Shure: I'm out of here.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 咱俩唱太难听
Katrina: We both sing so terribly.
Shure: 不管把我去开
Shure: No matter, I'm leaving.
Tasha:他不难听
Tasha: He's not terrible.
Tasha:是这个意思吗
Tasha: Is that what you mean?
Shure: 你会唱new boy
Shure: Do you know how to sing "New Boy"?
Shure: 听过吗
Shure: Have you heard it?
Lucia:你们坐车过来的话是不是有点远
Lucia: Did you guys drive here? Isn't it a bit far?
Shure: 是呀哈哈哈
Shure: Yeah, hahaha.
Katrina: 这可这人多一点
Katrina: There are quite a few people here.
Shure: 你觉得唱歌如何
Shure: What do you think about singing?
Tasha:非常不好听
Tasha: It's really bad.
Shure: 那我们唱哪首歌
Shure: So which song are we going to sing?
Shure: 我们唱那首西城男孩 吧
Shure: Let's sing that Westlife song.
Katrina: 好就是
Katrina: Okay, sure.
Katrina: 好这个我会打
Katrina: I can play this.
Shure: 好这个我不会弹
Shure: Okay, I can't play this.
Katrina: 这个太难了他明白
Katrina: This is too hard, he gets it.
Katrina: 这不嗨呀我以为这个摇滚的会嗨一点
Katrina: This isn't exciting. I thought this rock song would be more upbeat.
Katrina: 到了专业的余额是吧
Katrina: Now it's at the professional level, right?
Katrina: 这样给你拍一张
Katrina: Let me take a picture of you like this.
Katrina: 上小红书走了
Katrina: Let's post it on Xiaohongshu.
Shure: 这根本就不可以
Shure: This is totally not okay.
Shure: 用一把木的吉他给他
Shure: Use a wooden guitar for it.
Shure: 就是那种欢快跳搓
Shure: It's the kind of lively, jumpy song.
Shure: 水手
Shure: "Sailor."
Shure: 公园
Shure: "Park."
Shure: 这个很跳搓
Shure: This is very jumpy.
Katrina: 哎小陈夏天呢
Katrina: Hey, where's Xiao Chen? It's summer.
Katrina: 叫什么歌来着
Katrina: What's the name of that song again?
Shure: 水手公园那个旮旯乐队
Shure: "Sailor Park" by that corner band.
Jake:不唱英文真听不出来
Jake: You can't really tell without singing in English.
Shure: 哈哈确实哈哈
Shure: Haha, indeed, haha.
Katrina: 这能用吉他弹出来吗
Katrina: Can this be played on the guitar?
Shure: 可以吧
Shure: Probably.
Shure: 水手公园
Shure: Sailor Park.
Katrina: 上春晚
Katrina: Perform at the Spring Festival Gala.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Shure: 不行就是新造的人好吧
Shure: No, it's just newly created people, okay?
Jake:可以迎接他们一下
Jake: We can welcome them.
Jake:把他们拐到一个小边上
Jake: Lead them to a corner.
Katrina: 海域恋你听过吗
Katrina: Have you heard "Ocean Love"?
Katrina: 海域恋也行
Katrina: "Ocean Love" is good too.
Shure: 可以试试明天
Shure: We can try it tomorrow.
Katrina: 那就这个开场
Katrina: Then let's open with this.
Katrina: 这个就大家一起唱
Katrina: Everyone can sing this together.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Katrina: 这听过吗
Katrina: Have you heard this?
Katrina: 孙燕姿的第一天
Katrina: Sun Yanzi's "First Day".
Shure: 第一天
Shure: "First Day".
Shure: 想起来第一次告白
Shure: It reminds me of my first confession.
Tasha:尴尬的我看
Tasha: How awkward.
Jake:忙着唱别的歌去了
Jake: Busy singing other songs.
Shure: 心燥的人
Shure: Impatient people.
Katrina: 还下雨嘞这个人听过吗
Katrina: And it's raining. Have you heard of this person?
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Shure: 塔莎给的议建
Shure: Tasha's suggestion.
Tasha:没亲过吗
Tasha: Haven't kissed?
Shure: 这听过了
Shure: I've heard this before.
Katrina: 感觉这歌挺好唱
Katrina: I feel this song is quite easy to sing.
Katrina: 试一下不
Katrina: Want to give it a try?
Jake:这得一群人一起唱然后在啊啊啊
Jake: This needs to be sung by a group, and then, ah ah ah.
Jake:你这是蓝莓味的吗
Jake: Is this blueberry flavored?
Katrina: 哪首歌啊
Katrina: Which song?
Shure: 周楚除三害
Shure: "Zhou Chu Eliminates Three Evils".
Shure: 知道这个电影吗
Shure: Do you know this movie?
Katrina: 哦知道知道
Katrina: Oh, I know, I know.
Katrina: 但我没看
Katrina: But I haven't watched it.
Shure: 就是中间那个
Shure: It's just in the middle part.
Shure: 就是前段时间特别火的那个
Shure: It's the one that was really popular recently.
Shure: 棒棒棒挨个打死
Shure: Going "bang bang bang," hitting them one by one.
Shure: 好吧 那得想想
Shure: Okay, we need to think about it.
Katrina: 开场
Katrina: Opening
Katrina: 一般那开场还远着
Katrina: Usually, the opening is still far away.
Katrina: 我们居然用我的开
Katrina: We actually used my opening.
Katrina: 我的未来式开过
Katrina: My future opening.
Katrina: 哈哈好像那个
Katrina: Haha, it seems like that.
Shure: 我们我知道了
Shure: I know.
Katrina: 他是不是手机静音 我有时候会手机静音自已没发现
Katrina: Is his phone on silent? Sometimes I put my phone on silent and don't realize it.
Shure: 开心超人听过吗
Shure: Have you heard of Happy Superman?
Katrina: 我有时候会
Katrina: Sometimes I do.
Katrina: 手机应该听过
Katrina: The phone probably heard it.
Katrina: 应该 听过
Katrina: Probably heard it.
Tasha:哦我知道那个
Tasha: Oh, I know that.
Katrina: 哎 可以
Katrina: Hey, it’s okay.
Shure: 听过吗这首歌
Shure: Have you heard this song?
Jake:听过
Jake: Heard it.
Katrina: 好找这种耳熟能祥家喻户晓的
Katrina: It's easy to find those familiar and well-known ones.
Katrina: 哎怎么了
Katrina: Hey, what's up?
Katrina: 门口吗 3
Katrina: At the door? 3
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:人类都记住了
Jake: Everyone remembers it.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:来坐
Jake: Come sit.
Jake:哎最后一天唱点啥
Jake: Hey, what should we sing on the last day?
Katrina: 你们的朋友会唱歌吗
Katrina: Do your friends sing?
Lucia:卡拉OK的唱法吗
Lucia: Like karaoke singing?
Katrina: 对对对
Katrina: Yes, yes.
Jake:就就就这种唱法
Jake: Yes, that kind of singing.
Lucia:不会弹吉他
Lucia: Can't play guitar.
Jake:对就是
Jake: Yes, exactly.
Katrina: 不用不用唱
Katrina: No need to sing.
Katrina: 到时候反正他有音响
Katrina: Anyway, there will be speakers.
Katrina: 直接那个呗
Katrina: Just use that.
Katrina: 唱歌就搞个话筒
Katrina: For singing, just get a microphone.
Katrina: 然后唱歌也可以获得获得
Katrina: And you can sing and also enjoy it.
Alice:我会骑牛
Alice: I can ride a bull.
Alice:正威的唱法
Alice: Like Zheng Wei's singing.
Shure: 蛋黄的小裙
Shure: The little yellow skirt.
Shure: 蓬松的头发
Shure: Fluffy hair.
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
Katrina: 我们不是合唱吗
Katrina: Aren't we doing a chorus?
Katrina: 是合唱所以再挑两首歌
Katrina: It's a chorus, so let's pick two more songs.
Katrina: 一首就开场欢快一点
Katrina: One should be upbeat for the opening.
Katrina: 一首就是适合晚上的慢悠悠的那种
Katrina: And the other should be slow and suitable for the evening.
Katrina: 开场的话有听这个
Katrina: For the opening, have you heard this?
Katrina: 开心超人你听过吗
Katrina: Have you heard of "Happy Superman"?
Shure: 结尾想好
Shure: Think of the ending.
Jake:哈 哈哈可拉倒吧
Jake: Ha, haha, forget it.
Tasha:我的天
Tasha: Oh my god.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 可以整的
Shure: We can do it.
Jake:插点电插点电
Jake: Plug it in, plug it in.
Shure: 给我来一个宝
Shure: Give me a power bank.
Lucia:我需要一个充电宝
Lucia: I need a power bank.
Shure: 给我来个宝
Shure: Give me a power bank.
Shure: 这首歌叫啥来着
Shure: What's this song called again?
Tasha:好像就叫朋友吧
Tasha: I think it's called "Friend".
Tasha:啊对 不起
Tasha: Oh right, sorry.
Shure: 哈 哈哈哈
Shure: Ha, hahaha.
Katrina: 还没唱难忘今宵呢
Katrina: We haven't sung "Unforgettable Tonight" yet.
Katrina: 难忘今宵哎
Katrina: "Unforgettable Tonight", hey.
Katrina: 我觉得可以
Katrina: I think it's good.
Nicous: 这个好
Nicous: This is good.
Katrina: 我们还可以采取春晚的那种
Katrina: We can also do it like the Spring Festival Gala.
Lucia:每人唱一句
Lucia: Everyone sings a line.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
修厦:上春山是吧
Shure: Like the Spring Gala, right?
Tasha:然后
Tasha: And then...
Lucia:然后再大合唱了
Lucia: And then a big chorus.
Katrina: 也行也行
Katrina: That works too.
Katrina: 每人唱一句工作量就小一点
Katrina: If everyone sings a line, it's less work.
Lucia:17
Lucia: 17.
Jake:17没事多很多
Jake: 17? No problem, that's plenty.
Lucia:我信你
Lucia: I believe you.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:那给你一个
Jake: Here you go.
Lucia:没事没事不开玩笑
Lucia: No worries, just kidding.
Jake:那我给你三个
Jake: Then I'll give you three.
Lucia:行行行用完了我随时换
Lucia: Okay, okay, I'll change it whenever you're done.
Jake:好嘞好嘞
Jake: Got it, got it.
Tasha:筷子呢
Tasha: Where are the chopsticks?
Shure: 哦我需要个宝
Shure: Oh, I need a treasure.
Jake:你给你一个宝
Jake: Here, have a treasure.
Shure: 谢谢宝
Shure: Thanks, treasure.
Katrina: 你们有推荐的吗
Katrina: Do you have any recommendations?
Katrina: 就是开头比较欢快的
Katrina: Something with a cheerful start.
Katrina: 你把那几个弹给他们听一遍呗
Katrina: Could you play those few songs for them?
Katrina: 开心超人
Katrina: Happy Hero.
Shure: 大家
Shure: Everyone.
Shure: 听过开心超人吗
Shure: Have you heard of Happy Hero?
Lucia:no
Lucia: No.
Lucia:那个再见吧妈妈吗
Lucia: Is it that "Goodbye, Mom" song?
Shure: 什么是快乐星球
Shure: What is Happy Planet?
Katrina: 开心超人弹
Katrina: Play Happy Hero.
Jake:每人拧一个
Jake: Everyone take one.
Lucia:我洗个手
Lucia: I'm going to wash my hands.
Lucia:我刚从那个啥医院回来
Lucia: I just came back from the hospital.
Lucia:不敢直接接触吃的
Lucia: I don't dare to touch food directly.
Katrina: 你这是开心超人的歌吗
Katrina: Is this the Happy Hero song?
Shure: 啊是的
Shure: Yes, it is.
Katrina: 怎么缠着悲悲伤的感觉
Katrina: Why does it sound so sad?
Shure: 我可以把
Shure: I can...
Tasha:哎哎
Tasha: Hey, hey.
Katrina: 要怎么吃
Katrina: How do you eat this?
Tasha:还先蘸这个再蘸这个
Tasha: First dip it in this, then dip it in this.
Shure: 可是我刚刚舔过来的
Shure: But I just licked it.
Katrina: 哈哈你算了
Katrina: Haha, never mind then.
Tasha:蘸蘸汤
Tasha: Dip it in the soup.
Tasha:蘸蘸再蘸一蘸啊
Tasha: Dip it, then dip it again.
Tasha:然后蘸蘸这个
Tasha: Then dip it in this.
Jake:唉呀妈呜
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Shure: 有毒有毒
Shure: It's poisonous, it's poisonous.
Katrina: 黏黏的
Katrina: It's sticky.
Shure: 我没蘸东西
Shure: I didn't dip it in anything.
Katrina: 我没有词汇量
Katrina: I have no words.
Katrina: 我太屌了
Katrina: I'm so awesome.
Jake:我操
Jake: Damn.
Katrina: 香
Katrina: Fragrant.
Alice:轩
Alice: Xuan
Katrina: 嗯轩啊
Katrina: Hmm, Xuan, huh?
Alice:轩啊
Alice: Xuan, huh?
Shure: 轩哈哈
Shure: Xuan, haha
Jake:来
Jake: Come
Lucia: 这是什么
Lucia: What is this?
Jake:嗯来了来了来
Jake: Hmm, it's coming, it's coming
Lucia:谢谢嗯嗯
Lucia: Thank you, mm-hmm
Lucia:年糕吗
Lucia: Is this rice cake?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm
Alice:麻薯
Alice: Mochi
Jake:看看这个店
Jake: Look at this store
Tasha:可可的 和
Tasha: Cocoa and...
Lucia:这两个是什么味
Lucia: What flavors are these two?
Tasha:豆乳的和可可的
Tasha: Soybean and cocoa
Lucia:啊谢谢吃一个
Lucia: Ah, thanks, I'll have one
Katrina: 他0.5倍速
Katrina: He's at 0.5 speed
Lucia:可以蘸着吗
Lucia: Can you dip it?
Tasha:要多蘸
Tasha: Dip it more
Lucia:碗都要给我蘸走了
Lucia: I'm gonna dip the whole bowl
Tasha:这个蘸蘸
Tasha: Dip, dip
Katrina: 开心往前飞
Katrina: Happy, fly forward
Katrina: 快点
Katrina: Hurry up
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes
Lucia:我是不是跟奶油有什么仇啊
Lucia: Do I have a grudge against cream or something?
Shure: 多少多少学费
Shure: How much, how much is the tuition?
Tasha: 啊什么
Tasha: Huh, what?
Shure: 最重要
Shure: The most important thing
Tasha:哈哈 什么
Tasha: Haha, what?
Tasha:什么不要学费
Tasha: What, no tuition?
Lucia:我感觉我又该洗裤子了
Lucia: I think I need to wash my pants again
Lucia:我好像跟奶油有仇似的
Lucia: It's like I have a grudge against cream
Tasha:好那给我二成
Tasha: Okay, then give me twenty percent
Tasha:分成吧我亲力教教学
Tasha: Share the profit, I personally teach
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm
Lucia:有你去中国留学生多的地方肯定有
Lucia: If you go to places with many Chinese students, you'll definitely find it
Tasha:他说有没有竞争力
Tasha: He asked if it's competitive
Lucia:有竞争力啊
Lucia: It's competitive
Lucia:就是去中国留学生多的地方肯定有
Lucia: Just go to places with many Chinese students, you'll definitely find it
Tasha:那不是有市场吗
Tasha: Isn't that a market?
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yes.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Tasha:不是我的意思是啊
Tasha: No, what I mean is...
Jake:这也没多少
Jake: This isn't much.
Tasha:利润很大
Tasha: The profit is huge.
Jake:没关系不要看了
Jake: It's okay, don't look at it.
Lucia:我先放一下
Lucia: I'll put this down first.
Tasha:去办一个
Tasha: Go get one.
Lucia:拿瓶水
Lucia: Grab a bottle of water.
Tasha:开家店
Tasha: Open a store.
Lucia:这水应该可以喝吧
Lucia: This water should be drinkable, right?
Lucia:我刚看了
Lucia: I just checked.
Jake:喝喝好的
Jake: Drink it, it's good.
Lucia:医生让我多喝点水哦
Lucia: The doctor told me to drink more water.
Lucia:我想申请一下这疫苗能报销吗
Lucia: I want to apply for reimbursement for this vaccine.
Jake:呃能报能报
Jake: Uh, yes, it can be reimbursed.
Jake:报了
Jake: It's covered.
Lucia:好谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Great, thanks a lot.
Lucia:能算工伤吗
Lucia: Can it be considered work injury?
Lucia:我甚至期待项目结束还得再打两针
Lucia: I even expect to get two more shots after the project ends.
Jake:啊行行
Jake: Ah, okay, okay.
Tasha:没有去新疆学啊
Tasha: Didn't you learn in Xinjiang?
Tasha:不是这个不是在哪里学
Tasha: No, it's not about where you learn.
Tasha:这个没有在哪学
Tasha: It's not about where you learn.
Shure: 这不是假的吗
Shure: Isn't this fake?
Shure: 哎呦你这不听
Shure: Oh, you don't listen.
Lucia:万一我今天晚上发烧了的话
Lucia: What if I get a fever tonight?
Lucia:哈哈好
Lucia: Haha, okay.
Jake:好待会可以
Jake: Okay, we can do it later.
Lucia:请大家那个
Lucia: Everyone, please...
Tasha:会发烧的
Tasha: You will get a fever.
Lucia:帮我冻点冰水哈哈哈
Lucia: Help me freeze some ice water, haha.
Jake:好
Jake: Sure.
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Lucia:没有没有应该不会就
Lucia: No, no, it shouldn't happen.
Tasha:那不是假的吗
Tasha: Isn't that fake?
Jake:看看你你伤
Jake: Look at you, you got hurt.
Lucia:这个就是他
Lucia: This is it.
Lucia:这就到现在还在红中
Lucia: It's still red even now.
Lucia:看这和这个地方
Lucia: Look, it's here and here.
Lucia:对现在好像又比我下午好一点了
Lucia: Yeah, now it seems a bit better than this afternoon.
Tasha:都是假的呵呵呵
Tasha: It's all fake, haha.
Lucia:就我特还有点
Lucia: I still have a bit of...
Jake:OKOK
Lucia:就我确实还有点红然后
Lucia: I still have a bit of redness and...
Katrina: 我当时还特崇拜你来
Katrina: I used to admire you so much back then.
Jake:应该还行问题不大
Jake: It should be fine, no big issue.
Katrina: 不是说只只只只是那个店是假的吗就
Katrina: Didn't they say only the store was fake?
Lucia:对理论上应该问题不大但是
Lucia: Yeah, theoretically it shouldn't be a big problem, but...
Jake:多打几针几挺好
Jake: Just get a few more shots, it'll be fine.
Lucia:规定是必须要至少要打4次或者5针
Lucia: The rule is you need at least 4 or 5 shots.
Shure: 哎呀完了腿麻了动不了了
Shure: Oh no, my leg is numb, can't move.
Lucia:然后最少最少要打4针
Lucia: At least 4 shots.
Shure: 我靠 哇
Shure: Damn, wow.
Lucia:就是打5针
Lucia: That's 5 shots.
Lucia:就是28天
Lucia: In 28 days.
Lucia:然后隔多久
Lucia: And then how long...
Shure: 我靠动不了你帮我拿一会
Shure: Damn, I can't move, can you hold it for me?
Lucia: 隔一星期打一针
Lucia: One shot every week.
Shure: 我操腿麻了
Shure: Damn, my leg is numb.
Lucia:如果是打4针就是今天要打两针
Lucia: If it's 4 shots, then you need two shots today.
Lucia:对所以我两边都打了一针
Lucia: So I got a shot on both sides.
Jake:我以前也被猫抓了
Jake: I got scratched by a cat before too.
Jake:然后我我我是我是在美国住一个LMB
Jake: I was living in an Airbnb in the US.
Jake:然后被那边有一只猫抓了
Jake: And a cat there scratched me.
Jake:然后抓了就
Jake: And after it scratched me...
Shure: 没有可乐了
Shure: No more Coke.
Shure: 你的可乐就是我的可乐
Shure: Your Coke is my Coke.
Jake:我和房东房东说打过哦
Jake: I told the landlord and he said to get a shot.
Jake:然后我我我我也就是
Jake: So I... I... although I was really worried the first day, I didn't care later on.
Jake:虽然第一天很慌但是后来也不管了
Jake: Although I was really worried the first day, I didn't care later on.
Lucia:对我今天还专门去咖啡馆问了
Lucia: Yeah, I even went to the café today to ask.
Lucia:我说这这小狗有没有疫苗本
Lucia: I asked if the puppy had vaccination records.
Lucia:然后他们说就是就是
Lucia: They said, well, they haven't taken it for shots yet.
Lucia:这个狗现在的疫苗他们还没带去打
Lucia: But the kennel said it had shots.
Lucia:但是就是狗舍说打过
Lucia: But the kennel didn't provide the records.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Lucia:但是就是狗舍没有给他们给疫苗本
Lucia: But the kennel didn't provide the records.
Lucia:然后我觉得啊那要不然回去打一下吧
Lucia: So I thought, maybe I should get it vaccinated again.
Jake:还是不够踏实对
Jake: Still not quite reassuring, right?
Lucia:对不对
Lucia: Right?
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia:所以我就
Lucia: So I...
Lucia:然后我问了一下我我那个我家人
Lucia: Then I asked my family...
Lucia:我妈说他朋友养猫
Lucia: My mom said her friend has a cat...
Lucia:然后被自己家猫抓了
Lucia: And got scratched by her own cat...
Lucia:就也去打了
Lucia: So she went to get a shot too.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 我说可以去采一个吧
Shure: I said maybe we should go get one too.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Tasha: 如果不打的话怎么样
Tasha: What happens if you don't get the shot?
Lucia:然后我本来想着对
Lucia: So, I was thinking...
Lucia:就是我可能很快就打回来了啊
Lucia: I might just get it quickly...
Jake:我之被抓的时候
Jake: When I got scratched...
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:那种大长狗
Jake: By a big dog...
Jake:那小狗没听就没听见
Jake: The small dog didn't even notice.
Tasha: 我说如果没有打疫苗得上狂犬病会怎么样
Tasha: I heard if you don't get the vaccine, you could get rabies. What happens then?
Nicous: 马上死掉
Nicous: You'd die right away.
Lucia:因为那地方走去其实挺近
Lucia: Actually, it's pretty close to walk there.
Tasha:真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Katrina: 百分百致死率
Katrina: It's 100% fatal.
Lucia:对但是那个因为他那是值班嘛
Lucia: Yes, but you know, they have shifts...
Katrina: 如果你得了是前题
Katrina: If you get it, that is.
Lucia:然后所以我就要等一下
Lucia: So I have to wait a bit.
Tasha: 这么恐怖
Tasha: That's so scary.
Lucia:然后我还要再咨询一下他是怎么回事
Lucia: I need to ask more about what's going on.
Katrina: 那概率还很低
Katrina: But the chances are really low.
Shure: 大家有看到我的手机吗
Shure: Has anyone seen my phone?
Lucia:然后怎么打
Lucia: And how to get the shot...
Lucia:然后所以就稍微晚了一点
Lucia: So it's a bit delayed.
Shure: 嘿Siri
Shure: Hey Siri.
Katrina: 疫苗多少钱一针
Katrina: How much is the vaccine per shot?
Shure: 嘿Siri
Shure: Hey Siri.
Katrina: 你那疫苗多少钱一针
Katrina: How much is the vaccine per shot?
Shure: 在我的iPhone上播放声音算是
Shure: Play a sound on my iPhone.
Lucia:基本上算是100块钱一针
Lucia: It's about 100 yuan per shot.
Lucia:对但是要打五针或者四针
Lucia: But you need to get four or five shots.
Lucia:就是打四针的话
Lucia: If you get four shots...
Lucia:你就是第一天打的时候要打两针
Lucia: On the first day you need two shots.
Lucia:左右胳膊上各一针
Lucia: One shot in each arm.
Alice:这个疫苗价钱还不一样的吗
Alice: Are the prices for these vaccines different?
Lucia:对还有300的哦
Lucia: Yes, there are even ones that cost 300.
Lucia:但我觉得300一只有点太夸张了
Lucia: But I think 300 for one shot is a bit too much.
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia:而且就是
Lucia: And also...
Katrina: 他们的功能不都是抑制吗
Katrina: Aren't their functions all the same, to suppress?
Katrina: 难道还有什么抑制得快一点
Katrina: Is there one that suppresses faster or something?
Lucia:好像没啥区别
Lucia: Doesn't seem to be any difference.
Katrina: 对啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Alice:他是根据什么来给你选针的呀
Alice: How do they decide which shot to give you?
Alice:不知道
Alice: No idea.
Alice:这100多跟300多有什么区别啊
Alice: What's the difference between the one over 100 and the one over 300?
Lucia:不知道啊
Lucia: No idea.
Lucia:咱也不知道啊
Lucia: I have no clue either.
Alice:我们之前打了
Alice: We took...
Alice:就打完一一个就快2,000
Alice: Just one shot cost almost 2,000.
Katrina: 定歌定歌定歌定歌定歌
Katrina: Choose a song, choose a song, choose a song, choose a song.
Lucia:因为那地方走去其实挺近
Lucia: Because that place is actually pretty close.
Lucia:那你那那就是你说的这种可能是300一针的
Lucia: So the one you're talking about is probably the 300 per shot one.
Shure: 定歌快快定完歌
Shure: Hurry up and choose a song.
Katrina: 定完歌睡觉了
Katrina: Choose a song and then sleep.
Lucia:如果300多就打完了就是1500对吧
Lucia: If it's over 300, then the total would be around 1500, right?
Shure: 我睡觉觉
Shure: I'm going to sleep.
Alice:那个好像三针
Alice: That one seems like three shots.
Katrina: 定完歌写论文哎
Katrina: Choose a song and then write the paper.
Lucia:三针
Lucia: Three shots.
Alice:我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either.
Alice:反正我妈去打的
Alice: Anyway, my mom went to get it.
Katrina: 他们要严逼了
Katrina: They're going to be strict.
Lucia:我妈他朋友打的就
Lucia: My mom's friend got it too.
Lucia:也是100块钱一针的
Lucia: It was also 100 per shot.
Lucia:然后我觉得这应该就可以了
Lucia: And I think that should be fine.
Jake:OKOKOKOK
Jake: OK, OK, OK, OK.
Katrina: 要不听一下这歌
Katrina: How about we listen to this song?
Katrina: 这应该合唱出来会好听
Katrina: It should sound good as a duet.
Lucia:希望我今天晚上不要发烧
Lucia: I hope I don't get a fever tonight.
Lucia:医生说常见的副作用是可能会发烧
Lucia: The doctor said a common side effect might be a fever.
Jake:哦就是打疫苗发烧
Jake: Oh, so you get a fever from the vaccine.
Lucia:对打疫苗发烧对
Lucia: Yeah, you get a fever from the vaccine.
Shure: 来先听一下下歌
Shure: Let's listen to a song first.
Shure: 听一下歌
Shure: Listen to a song.
Shure: 这首歌大家听过吗
Shure: Have you all heard this song before?